a ps5 exclusive launch title has been
delayed
an xbox streaming stick might be on the
way and apex legend season 7 is adding a
ton of new content
i'm persia and this is your save state
for monday october 26th
the arcade card game destruction
all-stars was gonna launch on the ps5
but it isn't anymore the game will now
release in february 2021
and it's gonna be free on playstation
plus when it launches
unlike typical ps plus games all stars
will be available on the service for two
months
and don't worry if you've already
pre-ordered the game then you will be
getting a refund
the ps5 is still launching on november
12th and you're not going to want to
miss out on our weekly
next-gen gaming show generation next for
all of the updates until then
speaking of next gen xbox could have a
streaming stick on the way
and it could even be bundled up with
game pass xbox boss phil spencer said he
expects there to be more and more lower
priced hardware in the future
and part of microsoft's efforts to meet
that expectation
could be to offer xcloud on a streaming
stick that simply gets plugged into a tv
spencer also mentioned the stick could
even be bundled with game pass
so all you'd need to play is a
controller what do you think of an
xbox streaming stick that would let you
plug in and play game pass games
let us know in the comments apex legend
season 7 is shaking things up with a new
character
a new map and even more the new
character is named
horizon and she's an astrophysicist who
can manipulate gravity to both move
herself
and her enemies around olympus is the
third official map in apex and it's a
city in the clouds but there's even more
new game-changing stuff
season seven is also adding the trident
which is a vehicle that can transport
your whole squad around the map
there will also be a season seven ranked
series a battle pass
and a new social feature called clubs
which lets you build
smaller communities within the game
season 7 kicks off on november 4th and
will also be launching on steam the same
day
with the ability to transfer your
progress over from origin
this season is definitely going to be
interesting
for more of our daily content hop on
over to our channel
i hope you all have a strong start to
your week and be sure to reach your next
save state tomorrow
see you later
[Music]
you